In the previous exercise, you practiced querying for all entities
of a kind. Magnus has talked to you about querying
by kind and by property. So the next step is
for you to write the code and fill the search results
by property values. For example, you could find all the
conferences whose city property has a value London. To add
a filer to a query, you either call up the
filter method specifying the property and operate a filter on and
the value of the filter on. So, for example, if you
need to fill from the city property and the value London.
But let's suppose you already created the query and now you
want to add filters. After you create a query object you can't
change it. In other words, it's immutable. So to make changes
to your query you need to reassign the variable and this is
how you build up your query. So let's say this is
my original query where I'm getting all the conferences ordered by name.
So now to add my filter, I just reassign
query back to itself really but that makes a copy
of it and, in this way, you can keep adding
filters. And that's what you're going to be doing now